it's almost impossible to end a hit show
in a way that makes everyone happy but
thanks to rushed execution frustrating
character choices and other
inconsistencies a number of the hard
Game of Thrones fans are pretty annoyed
with how everything's checkouts here's a
spoiler filled examination of what we
think went wrong with the final season
of Game of Thrones for the first five
seasons show runners David Benioff and
DB White's were able to mostly follow
Martin's books as a direct templates and
many of the show's most beloved and
infamous moments including the execution
of Ned Stark and the red and purple
weddings were directly out of the source
material Benioff and Weiss did make some
welcome adjustments in the fifth book
Tyrion wanders around for what feels
like years before meeting Daenerys
whereas in the show they team up pretty
quickly but for the most part they stuck
to the literal script in front of them
however once the show's fifth season
ended so did the source material the
next book in Martin's series the winds
of winter is still unfinished
and once Benioff and Weiss run out of
source material that's around the same
time many fans started complaining about
being unsatisfied with the handling of
the show's overall story and writing
even though Martin himself guided them
through the final acts of the series
obviously Benioff and Weiss aren't
without talent since they built the show
fans grew to love but Martin is
naturally better at manipulating his own
story and problems began to arise when
the show runners were left to their own
devices it's understandable that us Game
of Thrones went on Emma came a bigger
and bigger hits HBO had wanted to
continue as long as possible but in 2015
Benioff and Weiss had a public dispute
of the network over how long it would
run expressing a desire to close out the
show after just seven seasons even
though Martin himself said the show
should be at least 13 seasons the show
runners and HBO eventually forced a deal
for an eight season run that would
abbreviate season 7 & 8 the former would
last for seven episodes or season eight
would only consist of six many fans
critical of the show have come to
proclaim that crumbing years worth of
build up an anticipation into a shorter
set of episodes created a new set of
problems making it all the more baffling
that the show runners insisted on these
short seasons without room to let the
story breathe the final batch of
episodes felt really rushed as a results
they stand in stark contrast to the
shows earlier seasons that focus on epic
journeys character developments
and long through lines as eighth season
began with two slower episodes that
hearkened back to the show's past
viewers got excited but then it started
barreling towards us grand finale
letting narrative threads come up short
and confusing ways characters jumped in
and out of the story at breakneck speeds
like bran sudden appearance and
disappearance from episode four being
just one example seemingly
insurmountable obstacles were overcome
in the blink of an eye like the longer
waited war with the night king and
characters seemingly teleported across
the map of Westeros when most of the
early seasons of the show were literally
about how long it took to get anywhere
fans knew Game of Thrones had to end
eventually but no one wanted it to feel
like it was trying to get there as fast
as possible with so much to wrap-up it's
ultimately disappointing that the
showrunners that the characters and
plots suffer on the road to the finish
line the biggest and most unfortunate
side effect of the rushed pace of game
of thrones' final season is that while
some of the plots and developments were
exciting and welcomed their execution
left something to be desired
while there were plenty of issues to
tackle Daenerys has battle strategies
most on Days exit your ones temporarily
impeccable aim Circe's may be real
pregnancy well how Bram became king
after doing basically nothing for the
entire season
the worst example is Daenerys cysts Adam
pivot into madness after seasons of
barbecuing her enemies and conquering
lands beyond Westeros fans were anxious
to see if the nearest would follow in
her father
heiresses footsteps and become the mad
Queen in the end it makes sense that she
did audiences have been tracking the
narrator's vengeful and hinged impulses
right from the beginning the only clear
buildup viewers got for Daenerys is
full-on descent into insanity was her
enraged reaction to Masson day's death
for a character who was always committed
to justice some felt it was an urn to
let her torch thousands of innocents in
King's Landing instead of letting
Daenerys experience a complex and
fascinating character arc as she
succumbs to the madness she once so
feared the show did her slow steady
growth to that point at a service and
arguably made a mockery of one of its
best and most interesting characters the
Narus is quick he'll turn to Mad Queen
is certainly one of the most obvious
examples of season eights and even
character developments but she's not the
only character to suffer during the
final season if you want to know where
season 8 went wrong with his characters
look no further than Jaime Lannister
Jaime started a game of Thrones off in a
pretty bad spots morally speaking you
know trying to kill a little kid
he caught you having sets of your twin
sister is definitely frowned upon the
things I do for love but over the course
of the show he became a fun favorite
thanks for redeeming character arc and
an utterly charming performance from
Nikolaj coster-waldau most of Jamie's
redemptive streak for Sanks - his
friendship and eventual tryst with
Brienne of Tarth who loved the man
beneath the armor and helped him escape
the clutches of his conniving cruel twin
sister however after sleeping with
Brienne Jamie deserts Winterfell which
he risked his life to save in the battle
against the army of the Dead to return
to his sister's side so why is he
suddenly leaving to go be with his
supervillain lover Jamie's only
explanation she's hateful some fans got
their hopes up that he might actually be
returning to King's Landing to kill his
sister but in the end
Jamie and Cersei reunited just to dine
each others arms with this one move it's
hard not to argue that Benioff and Weiss
and did years of character developments
giving one of the show's biggest
characters one of the least satisfying
conclusions they could have chosen and
let's not forget about the other half of
this pair of doomed dummies
Cersei one of the show's most
fascinating and twisted characters and
ostensibly one of the biggest threats to
the show's heroes spent much of season 8
drinking wine and idly staring off a
balcony only to suffer one of the series
most anticlimactic deaths it may make a
certain kind of sense for she and Jamie
to be reunited in the last moments but
seeing the show's most cunning and
cutthroat villains get taken down by a
pile of falling rocks it's just plain
and satisfying and this points to
another big issue with the show's final
season failing to pay off on the series
many years of buildup one of the major
strengths of Game of Thrones has always
its effective tension building and fans
were excited for huge storylines that
come to a head in the show's final
season make no mistake season 8 had
plenty of drama but there were still
several plots that ended up with some
pretty lackluster payoffs another
obvious example is a night king builds
up throughout the show's run as a
formidable villain who can raise entire
armies of the Dead with a flick of his
breast seeing gow you swoop in and take
him down might have been extremely fun
in the moment but in the end the entire
narrative of the night king and the true
history of the White Walkers was left
largely unexplained meanwhile the show
spends seven seasons building - the
revelry
that John was a secret Targaryen but
through it all out in the series finale
giving the throne to a boy with no claim
to it whatsoever season 8 had some
satisfying moments but ultimately it
suffered from a huge amount of build-up
that simply didn't pay off on the
subject of lots of build-up without much
payoff right from the beginning a game
of Thrones was rife of prophecies
focusing on everything from world
saviors to poisoned wombs and fateful
deaths since some of the prophecies came
true during the show's run like their
prediction made to Cersei regarding her
marriage and children it stood to reason
that the rest of the prophecies
introduced would end up being extremely
important
turns out this wasn't the case at all
with most of the show's prophecies
abandoned by the final season it's hard
to understand why they were ever
introduced Stannis was not the prince
who was promised that someone has to be
one of the earliest prophecies made in
the series concerns Daenerys and her
childbearing capabilities which is made
by a vengeful witch who tells Daenerys
that more or less she will never be able
to produce any heirs Daenerys fully
believes this telling John as much in
treating her dragons as a children but
in the end the nurses fertility at as
much importance as Ed Sheeran's bizarre
cameo Daenerys was also a possible
contender for a seemingly unimportant
theories about the Zora hi and the
prince or princess who was promised but
in the end those prophecies also fizzled
into nothing again it makes sense that
the series would make some cuts to the
narrative as it honed in on its final
episodes but after seasons of repeating
these prophecies seeing them come to
nothing as a disappointment
along with moments that ended up
happening off screen plenty of plots
from the previous seasons ended up on
the cutting room floor while not
completing every single narrative spread
on Game of Thrones is understandable it
feels wrong that so many huge
developments ended up having little to
no bearing on the show's eventual
conclusion for example Jon Snow went
through quite a journey throughout the
series becoming a strong and honorable
man who literally died and came back to
life for his people all before realising
his whole identity was allied told to
protect his life but in the end none of
that mattered at all since the show
shunted John back into the Nights Watch
without letting most of Westeros find
out there was another heir to the throne
Arya spent two seasons training with the
faceless man and while she might have
picked up the stealthiness and weapons
training that allowed her to take down
the night king it
seems odd that she didn't Face Swap once
at during the final season these
examples are just scratching the surface
after placing so much emphasis on the
religions of Westeros in previous
seasons from the red priests and
priestesses to the old gods and the new
those were all basically thrown out and
forgotten by the show's end some plots
will likely sacrifice for a reason but
this many feels kind of ridiculous it
would be impossible to include every
single character that ever appeared on
Thrones in the final season but is
frustrating that a few big names were
left out entirely
especially when comparatively new and
altogether annoying characters like
euron greyjoy were allotted plenty of
screen time shut up you idiot
anyway considering how important brand
turned out to be in game of thrones'
final episodes
it feels really wrong that me reread at
the faithful companion who dragged him
through the far north and saved his life
several times never showed up again
other faces entirely absent from the
final season at Daario naharis the Narus
his loyal mercenary and one-time
boyfriend and arias assassin mentor
jaqen H'ghar
both of whom seem to have him finish
stories left to tell and after a chance
meeting in season 7 arias rogue wolf
Lemuria is never relevant again we'd
have traded any of your own scenes for
some of those forgotten favorites to
show up again no seriously dude shut up
one of the biggest questions of the
final season was who would actually rule
over Westeros ultimately the question if
he would physically take the throne was
suss in the garbage went rogue on after
fighting Daenerys dead torched the chair
out of existence but the fact remained
that the Seven Kingdoms still needed a
leader and soon the Seven Kingdoms
didn't exactly end up with the leader
the six kingdoms did after Sansa
demanded independence for the north and
became its queen the new king of the
rest of the kingdoms ended up being none
other than bran Stark who seemed to
already have a full-time job staring
into space as with Daenerys is descent
into madness bran becoming King makes
some sense in the context of the show
overall but so many fans however arrive
there feels basically absurd
Tyrion argues that branch should be made
King because he had the best story of
all but let's remember that this
character is sitting between his two
sisters with way more interesting
stories and actual leadership skills
Sansa became the badass queen in the
north
while aria transformed into a super
assassin and literally saved the entire
world but sure let's give the crown to
the kid with mind-control powers who
just sat there and did nothing to beat
his mortal enemy that Mike King at least
they didn't give their new king a really
insulting nickname or anything right or
have brand the broken
well nevermind check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
loop of videos about Game of Thrones are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]